little foxy
hello cat
there's me there's my camp
and all the way over here they're all
over here
look at that little cove at camp
there are two sets of footprints in the
ground because i have two
feet because i'm the main character of
the movie
so i'm here in beautiful ensance
braziaron desert doing what i have to do
surviving
living off the land i'm so thirsty
and i'm dying pretty good place to die
so might as well get to it already
in the desert in the sea of sand
they come all the way out into the
wilderness so they can sit in their cars
they just love it they love sitting down
they're like how can i sit down some
more over here
we're also making noise wanted to share
this beautiful moment
in these sand dunes while the sun
has set the beautiful pink
hue of the sky
illuminating the sand dunes which are
silky and smooth
and it's just a really cool moment look
at the line of
ufology this is just too strange
to not be strange look at that little
beetle
he's just been rolling all over the
place
i picked him up and put him outside the
fire pit
but he went right back in
he's just rolling around
my foxy little friend
it's good to see you again
what's up guys it's just me hans came
here
on top of a mountain in the
el cargo muchacho mountain range
and i'm just chilling out in this
beautiful beautiful scenery
how beautiful is this i'm just doing it
right now
and you can't stop me even if you tried
you don't know where i am actually i
just told you